2018 draft wasn't all that long ago the
three quarterbacks of the five taken in
round one who have become
pass on the pass fail side because
that's all that matters the first three
years pass or fail josh rosen fail not
entirely his fault but clearly fail sam
darnold how could it not be fail he got
traded to the carolina panthers he could
still flip that f to a p
but for now
we're not thinking about his second
contract we are thinking about second
contracts for the other three guys taken
in round one that year baker mayfield of
the browns first overall selection josh
allen of the bills seventh overall pick
and then
with the final pick in round one it was
the ravens trading back in to get
quarterback lamar jackson
who was the 2019 nfl mvp not a bad way
to cap your second season in the
national football league so now this
dance continues of who's going to get
paid who goes first i continue to
believe
that the two guys who have agents
traditional agents baker mayfield and
josh allen they want to let lamar
jackson go first we reported over the
weekend that the negotiations even
though there's a lot of confusion and i
think some incorrect reporting about
who's involved in the negotiations for
example lamar jackson's mother isn't
negotiating
on his behalf jackson is the one who's
doing the negotiation and he's being
advised by others but those negotiations
moving smoothly
i think he's the first one to do the
deal
i think the bills and josh allen need to
do a deal because
like jackson
i think it's clear now
that josh allen
is a top 10 if not top five quarterback
and you do have to ride
that guy
as long as you possibly can that's the
raven's attitude with lamar jackson and
i think it is or at least should be the
bill's attitude with josh allen this is
our guy we're gonna see how it goes
we're gonna get a contract in place that
we believe
uh is appropriate
is fair
and that sends the message this is the
guy for the foreseeable future and
beyond the ravens definitely feel that
way about jackson the bills as i said
should feel that way about josh out with
mayfield
you know there's some thought in league
circles that the browns would like to
give it one more year even though it's a
calculated risk
because let's say mayfield wins the mvp
in 2021 and when you think about how mvp
gets determined
one seed in each conference the
quarterback of the one seed that that's
the guy who has the inside track two
guys have the inside track afc one seed
quarterback and nfc one seed quarterback
if the browns
end up
taking the number one seed and look the
afc is very top-heavy this year so it's
by no means an easy proposition but if
they end up there mayfield's got a good
shot at being the mvp and he he was
great the second half of last year as
the browns ascended
if the browns wait a year and if
mayfield ends up
being
one of the truly best quarterbacks in
the nfl it's going to cost a lot more
next year to get him signed than it
would this year
the question becomes this what would the
browns pay this year and how close is
that to what mayfield wants mayfield has
always been very confident in himself
and that's great you need that to thrive
at the nfl level how big of a gap right
now is there between the brown's
willingness to pay and mayfield's
expectations it may just be that they
can't find a way to make the two sides
come together this year and they have to
wait a year and that's a gamble for
mayfield if mayfield says no to that
bird in the hand
that bird could shrink by next year if
he gets injured if he has a rough season
if he regresses
and the reason that this is all relevant
the two contracts done for the 2016
number one and number two overall picks
jared goff carson wentz
three years after their career started
they got their second contract two
seasons after doing those second
contracts
their teams
and look we don't even have to i mean
it's no it's it's a given they regret it
we don't have to put anyone under a lie
detector test to get to the truth
clearly they regret it the eagles traded
carson wentz to the colts and
the rams tucked jared goff into the
matthew stafford trade and
as a practical matter gave up a first
round pick to get that contract off the
books so that that is the cautionary
tale and i thought it was funny back in
may when brown's gm andrew berry said
it's not a cautionary tale those
contracts the wence and the golf
contracts it is it is and i think the
fact
that barry said it isn't
is
kind of an effort to
obscure the reality that the browns are
going through that analysis very heavy
on analytics
and
when when you focus on that aspect you
understand more than any other team that
your players really are interchangeable
parts and the question becomes
if we pay baker mayfield what he wants
that's one approach the other approach
with all these great quarterbacks coming
out of college every year
could we do
dollar for dollar a lot better at the
quarterback position mayfield at
whatever his magic number is
rookie at a slotted deal for three years
before you get into what the next
round of financial compensation is
don't be surprised if it goes that way
don't be surprised if mayfield wants so
much that the browns say as a business
proposition we're not doing it they're
facing that challenge in the coming year
with nick chubb one of the best running
backs in the nfl but you know what you
can find another nick chubb in round two
round three round four round five round
undrafted there are plenty of running
backs out there every year it's part of
the challenge and it's one of the
problems of having a great team it's
easy to be driven by analytics and that
type of analysis when you don't have
star players when you do have star
players when fans are invested in those
players when fans have purchased the
jerseys of those players becomes a lot
harder to treat them like the
interchangeable parts that a team that
is so driven by analytics would prefer
to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports